welcome back to pierre's morgan on
censor fans of marilyn monroe have
slammed kim kardashian for wearing her
iconic happy birthday mr president dress
on the uh met gala red carpet in new
york footage released overnight shows
reality star struggling to get into the
dress in fact the fragile gown worth
five million dollars had to be left
unzipped because it wouldn't fit miss
kardashian's expansive derriere
then there are fears that she may have
irreparably damaged the dress
all for an ego boost and a photo op a
lot of marilyn singing of course to
president john f kennedy uh one of the
most famous moments in history really um
i'm joined now by not one but two
marilyn monroe impersonators one uh is
heather cheney performs in las vegas and
susie kennedy based here in the uk both
looking fabulous ladies if i may say so
so good evening to both of you thank you
um let me start with you heather because
you don't agree with me do you think
that actually uh this reality
billionaire bimbo kim kardashian
tarnishing maryland's memory in this
disgraceful manner is good explain to me
why
i think it's good because it's bringing
maryland back to the light for the
younger generations that don't know her
i mean
whether or not
i agree that kim kardashian being the
person to do that for this particular
dress uh that's a whole nother story uh
but it is we're talking about it we're
here we're debating it we're talking it
so it is bringing marilyn's memory into
fruition and and the dress is beautiful
and the more people see it the better
you see i think when i see you two
ladies
when i say you both dressed as matt you
look fabulous you look like you're
paying a lovely tribute to marilyn
monroe and it's the spirit of her that
you're representing which i can totally
get and appreciate and respect but you
know susie when i see kim kardashian a
reality star
you know basically nicking marilyn's
dress and even worse then got presented
by the by the museum which lent him the
dress they they gave her a bit of
marilyn's hair look at this clip
i know it's crazy pierced good to see
you again by the way wait one second i
want to play the clip first
this is her actually getting marilyn's
that is marilyn's hair
oh my god i'm literally
going to do some crazy booty
[Laughter]
and i channel her with this impressive
special to me thank you so much
i mean i'm sorry susie what is kim
kardashian doing with marilyn monroe's
hair
right she's gonna do some voodoo stuff
with it and channel her she couldn't
channel marilyn monroe marilyn monroe
was one of the great goddesses of
hollywood history not someone who got a
kit off on some sex tape with her
boyfriend
i mean who would say that and i mean
marilyn monroe um
died tragically at 36 to say you're
going to get her hair and do crazy
voodoo
with it it's just a height of disrespect
she said to she respects her but
you know you pulled that dress that
didn't fit you i've worn mary monroe's
real dresses her costumes that were worn
on studios and sets the happy birthday
dress was so personal to marilyn it was
her moment and marilyn's lost everything
she lost her childhood she lost her
loves she lost her life that one dress
that iconic moment was so marilyn and
it's been now
stolen and i remember kim kardashian's
dad was part of the o.j simpson team
that said if the glove don't fit you
must have quit well kim the dress didn't
fit so quick
i mean look heather i gotta say i'm with
susie on this because when i see her
trying to bust her way into that dress
she clearly doesn't fit it and that's
despite we're gonna play a clip now of
kim kardashian talking about trying on
the dress and realizing it doesn't even
fit let's listen to this
so they came with like armed guards and
gloves and
i tried it on it didn't fit me and so i
looked at them and i said give me like
three weeks and i i had to lose 16
pounds
down today to
be able to fit this but i it was such a
challenge it was like a roll right i was
determined yeah i was determined to win
it
sorry what does she mean a role she's
not an actress
marilyn monroe was a goddess of the
silver screen kim kardashian is a
reality tv star a role was she talking
about heather
i listen
in in in real marilyn was actually sewn
into the dress so i find it
um not surprising that they had to do it
for kim k and i myself i have no idea
how she got the back end of her in the
dress well she didn't she didn't heather
that's the point she couldn't get her
back into the dress so they left it open
and then covered it up apparently
yes
apparently i haven't seen all the
footage as of yet um it's very unsightly
and in my view very demeaning to the
legacy and memory of marilyn monroe
that's my point
exactly
exactly but i come from a place of like
working in a theme park i've seen
people roaming through over and over
with images of maryland that are
frankly far worse with like the skull
face i mean the images of maryland have
been tarnished for years and this is
just this is a little different because
it's bigger in the spotlight because
it's the infamous happy birthday dress
but somebody you know tarnishing the
image of marriage okay
i don't really agree but uh susie final
word to you quickly
it's just ridiculous and the sad thing
is now is that marilyn monroe had a
moment in history and kim kardashian has
clung onto that and she's you're right
pierre she's not an actress she's a
reality star and i think it's a very sad
day for that dress it's tarnish now and
it's it's been hijacked like a mark
chapman hijacked john lennon and i'm
here in liverpool and that dress was
marilyn's and it'll ever be the marilyn
kim kardashian dress and that's a really
sad day for what you know kim had her
own thing do your own thing i'm an
impersonator i don't have to do my own
thing that's what i do kim was different
she could have made her moments okay
steal it i agree with you can i leave
though with the pair of you just saying
happy birthday mr president to me in
maryland boys
happy
birthday
mr morgan
happy birthday
to you heather
oh you want me to go yeah go on
birthday
he's loving this today
to you
[Music]
happy
birthday
to you
happy birthday
little pears
happy birthday
to you
fabulous now that is the spirit of
marilyn monroe thank you ladies heather
susie really appreciate it keep doing a
great work living up to the
image and memory of the great maryland
thank you very much thank you that's it
thank you